I love this song it was great thanks
guys
alright hi everyone I'm Amanda Bradford
I'm founder and CEO of the league and
today I wanted to talk to you guys about
one of my favorite activities which is
pre gaming do I have a clicker oh here
it is
I'm sure a lot of you know about this to
you well versed in college and good news
it applies after college too so the way
I see it is a product launch is
basically identical to throwing a
kick-ass party and behind every great
party is actually a really epic pregame
if you don't throw a lot of parties ask
your friends that do and I guarantee you
they will agree with me this is kind of
like the little secret to how to host an
awesome party so quickly just give you
overview of what I want to talk about
today is first is some background on my
company the league myself how I define
success for a product launch the
benefits of pre-gaming of which there
are many
the art of pre gaming and it is an art
the main event itself which is your
product launch and then we can do Q&A so
quick background what is the league
what is the league it's a great question
it's changed a lot actually in the last
year and a half but you know the league
is a dating app it were iOS only and the
idea behind the league is for kind of
smart intelligent educated people that
want to date on kind of ambition and
intelligence and not just play hot or
not all day so we use Facebook and
LinkedIn to double authenticate all of
our users this serves two purposes one
it lets you see more context about a
profile so you're not just making
decisions based on looks it also lets
you have more privacy so we block you
from your LinkedIn coworkers we block
you from your LinkedIn connections we
block you from your Facebook friends and
I really designed that for myself I
usually work with a lot of guys in tech
and when I did my internship in finance
and the last thing I wanted was for them
to kind of
the deciding yes or no on my dating app
profile is pretty awkward so yeah so the
social graphs we use from Facebook and
LinkedIn let you prevent that and not
have any awkward struggles around your
coworkers and then on top of that we
really curate the community so everybody
everybody who signs up goes to a wait
list and we keep a very like small
engaged community and we pull off the
wait list to ensure that the community
stays like very high-quality if you have
a photo where you're crushing a beer on
your forehead you may be on the wait
list for a little bit longer um and if
you're using fake photos or spammy
accounts like we kind of screen all of
the noise out that you see on a lot of
other dating apps
alright so Who am I so I graduated from
Stanford Business School and prior to
that I had been at Google and Salesforce
and a variety of kind of engineering
slash sales roles so I got my undergrad
at Carnegie Mellon and information
systems and graduated knowing that I
want to do something in technology so I
joined salesforce.com
and went to Google went to business
school did some internships in business
school in venture capital and mobile
startups and I think at the at the end
of it I I knew I really wanted to do
something in entrepreneurship and I
study that in in business school and I
wasn't quite sure what I wanted to do
and I kind of get into it to why I
started the league but that's kind of my
background so I call myself I want to be
tech executive I guess for most of my
career and why am i up here talking I
think that's a good question you should
be asking because there's a lot of
people up here that are talking that
have achieved a lot more than we have at
the league we're still very early-stage
we're dealing you know have the same
fundraising struggles as many of you
guys probably do and but I think why I
why I'm up here is that we did a really
good job of launching our product from
nothing and to gaining brand awareness
in a pretty short time and I think our
users you know we're really key reason
to that and that's sort of why I'm
talking here about the pregame and why
it was so important and you know mobile
apps in general in the consumer space
are notoriously very hard to launch it's
really you know every day I think
there's at least like 30 new dating apps
that go live on the App Store it's a
very noisy crowded environment and it's
really hard to get kind of above the
noise and I think we did a really good
job at that I'm here to teach you the
tricks that I use to do that but I think
that's that's why I was invited to speak
so I'm excited to share the secrets with
you guys so why did I start the league a
quick like story about myself a little
personal I guess I got out of a
five-year relationship in November of my
second year of Business School you could
say I went on a dating app bender in
December
I tried pretty much every dating app
there is Under the Sun had a lot of the
same my complaints on each one I really
didn't want my co-workers seeing me I
wanted to be able to filter on like
intelligence and ambition and it's
really hard to do that and I also wanted
kind of that same community feeling I
had at Stanford where you're in this
environment where everyone is super
ambitious and they value kind of
intelligence and drive and they want
that in a relationship and I went on a
couple dates in the wild and I realized
that kind of being an alpha female and
being super career driven isn't always
what everybody wants to date and I think
I wanted kind of a way to qualify out
those people without having to go and
you know do a two-hour coffee date to
realize that it was a waste of my time
and their time so that was kind of the
inspiration behind it and you can see
here my wireframes
that I started and I guess this slide is
really just encourage you guys that you
don't have to have like VC funding and
you don't have to have a technical
degree I mean this is I use the balsamic
to just mock up what I wanted to build
the really MVP functionality and I use
my second semester in Business School to
do that because in business school your
second semester you're not doing much
studying so I really focus on this
project I did an independent study with
one of my professors and you know my
goal was to launch it by the end of the
by the time I graduated and you know I
worked on figuring out how to get it
built and I think this is like I guess I
want to stop here and just sort of
explain a little bit about like why I
always encourage people to kind of take
the leap a lot of people get stuck in
this phase of like okay it's gonna cost
me twenty thousand dollars to find a
developer like what do I do I need an
investor
and I always whenever people come and
tell me that I say like how much you
spend on vacations how much you spend on
clothes how much you spend on going out
to eat I like boozy dinners and
expensive places how much do you spend
on ubers and like kind of tally all that
up and decide if you know is this is
actually like I'm way more exciting
investment you not only learn but you
also have the opportunity to potentially
change your whole career path for maybe
twenty thousand dollars of development
cost and you think about how much you
spend on college I mean it's it's just I
guess I always encourage people to
reframe the investment and not get
sticker shock on kind of investing in
your yourself which is essentially what
you're doing so I'll get off my soapbox
that's just my little motivational
speech here um so how did we launch and
I like to quote my bro-tastic friend
here and say you know we pre gamed
harder than a lot of startups party so
first I want to talk about what you know
what is a successful product launch and
how do you define that and you know the
definition of a product launch you guys
know this is when you turn your product
on and people show up and hopefully they
stay maybe they spend money but at the
end of the day you want them to show up
and that's exactly the same thing as a
party so you have a party you say it's
at 8:00 p.m. at 8:00 p.m. you're there
hoping that people will show up it's the
same kind of anxiety it's the same prep
work you need to do and so when I think
about how to explain how to launch a
product well I always you know use the
analogy of like how would you throw a
really awesome large party so what
defines what defines a good product
launch and the way I think about this is
what are my investors ask as soon as we
launch our product they ask you how many
people showed up how many daily active
users you have they ask you what is your
engagement like are people interacting
are they talking like are people having
kind of fun what's your retention are
they staying do they check it out and
leave because it sucks
and what's your K factor that's virality
like are people telling friends are they
bringing in people and if you think
about like a party when you call your
friend and tell them to meet you at a
party downtown they ask you the same
freaking questions they say how many
people are there man like I don't know
I'm watching house of cards
oh is it fun like how fun is it really
and then
how much longer are you staying by the
time if I get up off the couch put
clothes on are you even gonna see one
you're still going to be there and then
who else is there you know are there you
know for singles it's often like are
there single people there but you want
to know that it's a healthy and vibrant
party and it's exactly the same as any
consumer products so all right so so yes
parties are an investment and I think
again I think it's like the perfect
analogy in a way more fun analogy to
think about when you're thinking about
how to launch your product so the dirty
secret is that you don't even have to
have that good of a party you really
just need an epic pregame and pre games
are awesome because there's no
expectations for free games they're
really cheap and people just feel
special for being able to go to a pre
game so it's sort of like you don't even
need to spend money on a band or crazy
you know food and drinks and open bar
you just kind of have a really good
pregame so the benefits of pregame I
mean are quite a bit so sorry about this
guys so why does one attend a pregame
you guys notice from college but you
know free boost that's one thing that's
what I called the value and when you're
underage this is really high value right
like you would go to almost any pregame
if you're 19 you can't get your hands on
alcohol and even if the weirdest person
across the hall has a pregame you're
probably gonna show up so that's that's
a kind of part of the value you need to
offer then you also get to have input on
the playlist on what drinking games
you're playing it gets - you get to kind
of like define the party and I think as
you think about it as like from a beta
testing perspective you get to have
impact on the features maybe you think
the green that they're using is really
ugly you could tell the designer that
and they might change the green before
they launch that's like really exciting
for someone to be able to kind of change
how the whole party is going you get to
have real conversations versus
superficial ones you know what parties
you're yelling over music asking people
like hey what's up but at pre games you
can actually find out what you know
where that person is from what they're
thinking about what they're passionate
about you actually get to know people
and I like to think of that as like
you're you're kind of getting really
deep engagement early on you get to
arrive at a party with a tribe or a
family I think you know you can think
about when you're
line for the bathroom or you lose your
purse you have kind of people that are
sort of there for you and and with you
and I think you feel like you have a
family to depend on and and that makes
you stay longer ultimately and then you
get to you know at the pre-party you can
charge your phone you can put your coat
in there in the bedroom even hang it up
you get to use a master bathroom like
you get this kind of VIP access and so I
think these are kind of why as a pre
gamer you like going to these and not
why a lot of times the pregame is way
more fun an actual party because you
have all this stuff and then you can
take it from the host perspective so if
I'm hosting a huge New Year's Eve party
why would I like add more work to my
plate and host a pregame on top of that
like talk about you know more stress
right but it's actually way a really
really good investment especially if
that party is really critical and when
it's a product launch it's probably the
most critical moment of your company and
pre-games I'm sure the number one thing
for game to do is this number one point
which is they show up and they show up
on time so I don't know if any of you
have had a party where you tell your
friends to show up at 8:00 and they come
at 9:30 but that's my friends and I've
had a plenty of parties without a
pregame and I let me tell you the person
that comes right at 8:00 p.m. is not
usually your friend is the person you'd
lead and you know the least have the
least in common with and you're not even
sure you remember their name and it's
like a really awkward moment and then
you come and then you're like where are
my friends it's getting you know it's
9:00 let's just party sort of lame so
the number one thing that pre games do
is ensure that like you have a good
crowd there when the party opens up the
next thing it does is ensures that you
have like high engagement at your party
so you have you know your pre gamers
have already kind of caught up with each
other and now they're ready to meet new
people right so they're they're like
outgoing they have had a couple drinks
they're going to engage with other
people and welcome them to the community
say hey check out the band back here you
know they're gonna be kind of part of
your host committee and I think that's
really important to have as many people
sort of you know welcoming your new kind
of strangers to the party as possible
pre gamers also feel a lot more
commitment to the party so if you think
about it if I have you know thirty
people over to my apartment I tell them
how hard I've worked on this New Year's
Eve party how nervous I am about it how
I really want everyone to have a good
time like your pre gamers feel you and
they like
okay I'm gonna help her have a really
good party and they're committed and
even if even if the party is kind of
lame
they'll stay longer than they should
because they're they're there for you
they kind of know the whole story and I
think that's really important to
mitigate kind of mitigate the risk that
your party isn't that great
and in the last pieces they'll get their
friends to join them so I think you know
think about this when you're going to a
party you know you're gonna be there for
hours on a Saturday I don't know about
you guys what I call my friends and I
say hey come meet me at this party that
way I can catch up with my friends and
go to the party and sort of kill two
birds with one stone so I think as you
think about why you know why you want to
have a pregame it it really helps to
trying to get this core group of users
invested so the art of the pregame so
this is sort of where I tell you what
what we actually did with the league and
the first part you need to remember is
it's exactly like hosting a party but
the secret is there's like zero
expectations so it's way cheaper and
it's a lot more kind of easy to do on a
shoestring budget
so you got to do the same the same
activities so build an invite list get
people to show up and then act cool when
they're there so I'll go into like what
I mean by that but first this is the
probably where you should spend the most
amount of time and this is building your
invite list and I like to say use the
VIP approach this is the least scalable
the most time-consuming but also the by
far the most effective and this is where
you actually are meeting people in
person like over the course of months
and you're you're putting a face with
the name you're telling them about your
company but you're not selling them
anything you're not pitching you're just
getting to know them as people just as
like making friends like you're a new
person in town I mean it's it's really
the same thing you're just sort of
building your contacts and then I think
the other piece is the lurker socialite
piece where you go to these large-scale
events and your friends aren't going to
keep going with you because you'll need
you know you're gonna be going out a lot
during this phase and people that aren't
building a business don't want to go out
five nights a week so you're gonna have
to be comfortable going out by yourself
talking to people being the kind of
weird lurker person that is there and
just goes up in strikes up conversations
and I think getting confidence with that
and being able to do that and not be
creepy is you know a skill that is
definitely worth gaining and I you know
I did that a lot I would go and tell
people you know you slip in that you're
building something but it's not the
focus
sation the focus of the conversation is
just really getting to know them as
people understanding you know how they
could potentially be helpful to you in
the future but not again not scaring
them or pitching them or asking them to
sign up for anything you just want to be
you know you're basically just building
your contacts and then the last piece is
door-to-door sales I like to think about
this as like when you're a freshman and
you want to have a pregame you go around
everyone in your dorm and say hey I'm
having a pregame in my room at 8:00 do
you want to come and you're essentially
extending an invitation right and
nobody's going to be offended or upset
that you are extending them an
invitation to an event with door-to-door
sales you don't want to just go and be
like hey I'm Amanda starting a dating
app will you sign up like nobody wants
that's nobody wants that knock on their
door like don't do that so make sure
you're inviting them to something that
could add value to their life and you're
you're doing it in a way that you're
giving them something right you're not
asking them for anything you're giving
so again this is the most effective
approach the next the next approach is
the network approach I think you should
do this but don't spend too much time on
it it doesn't like convert to the super
highly so you know definitely email your
fraternity brothers and your you know
your brother have him emailing his
fraternity brothers and Facebook posts
and do all that stuff I call that like
kind of their digital network but I
wouldn't you know don't expect this to
be like your golden ticket or anything
this is going to get you you know some
downloads or some conversions but these
are not gonna be your ambassadors and
they're not gonna care that much about
you so just do it but don't don't expect
a lot from it and then I try to avoid
that I have no friends approach but this
is where you had to make an ad or your
Craigslist posting for your pregame and
this kind of reeks of like desperation
and it's like imagine if you're in
college and you saw someone putting in a
Craigslist posting for their pregame in
their dorm room like you're kind of like
man you can't you don't have anyone you
could have invited that without you know
posting your Craigslist so and it
doesn't mean you shouldn't do this ever
but I just again like the people you're
gonna get from this are usually not the
kind of people you want kind of in your
core group of ambassadors so the next
step is getting people to show up and
this is where you actually give them
something that they can't get otherwise
so what we did like you know think back
to college booze was a huge draw that
was obviously what you know
percent of Hardee's decided to give to
get people to show up but I mean there's
other things you can do so you can see
here we had an MBA happy hour and we
didn't even have that much free booze I
think I got like ten cases or ten
bottles of wine sponsored but the draw
here was the MBAs had just graduated and
they really wanted to meet each other
and nobody had like created an event for
them to meet each other so that was what
I did I wasn't even about the league it
wasn't even about dating or singles or
not singles it was just an event for
MBAs two minute to meet and we got a ton
of people to show up just for that like
one thing that we could offer which was
connecting with like-minded people from
like a similar industry that that wanted
to connect anyway I did a girls night
where we left a clothing store we left
it open and an extra two hours and let
people come in and get a discount and so
that's another example of kind of
offering them some access and exclusive
thing that they can't get otherwise we
did an open bar so this is the one area
we did spend money we spent $3,500 and
we did an open bar for two hours and we
did require people to have the app
downloaded to get in but you know when
you're offering them an open bar like
that's a pretty good ROI for the person
and we're also offering like singles and
people like coming were there single
people so that was our two drawers but
so this was kind of the one where we did
sort of ask for for signups and we did
check signups but you know we also gave
them a pretty good pretty good return on
that download you can see here we had a
really good turnout this is our Redford
party and just to like caveat this this
is all before we even launched the
product so we had a product in the app
store that literally was just like
what's your facebook and we got their
email address and that's all we did and
so everyone like kind of made fun of me
because I'm like oh is that the waitlist
app like I wasn't open for anyone and it
runs like when are you launching that
it's been like seven months of parties
and so we definitely pregame for a
really long time and here's one more
trick we used is just giving people free
classes so we worked with SoulCycle and
Barry's boot camp to have like league
specific classes you can see here I got
people to come to a you know free these
are $30 classes that they got for free
because we worked out a deal and then we
also got a yacht we rented a yacht for a
fleet week which is really again hard
thing to get on your set on your own
like all the boats are sold out so we
had that to get people to go and we
actually charged tickets for
this party so we didn't even spend any
money on it and again these are all just
examples of like giving your user
something that they can't get otherwise
and this is the boat it was really fun
party so then the last pieces be cool so
don't force them to listen to a sales
pitch the worst thing you can do is like
make them hear something before you give
them alcohol or before you give them you
know people to talk to so just just make
it a fun party they'll start to
associate positive feelings with your
brand and with you as a founder and and
don't worry about the fact that like
nobody downloaded your app but they came
to your party like this is part of the
sort of pre pre work you need before you
start really asking them for things so
if you ask too early before you've
gained trust it's just it leaves a bad
taste in people's mouth so when to in
the pregame we've all been to a pregame
that doesn't actually go to the party
right so you have too much fun or too
much alcohol so what we did is we
actually put a hard stop in the you know
hard line in the sand and said at 250
girls and 250 guys are going to launch
our alpha and so you can see here all
the pre gaming we did from July to
November and we actually put in the APIs
screen so that our users knew when we
were launching and we're like okay we
only need to you know 100 more guys 100
more girls call-to-action for our users
who had downloaded it to help us get to
that kind of final mile and this also
held us accountable so that we actually
launched and didn't have too much fun
with the pre-party and then so now
you're at the main event right so you're
actually at the launch launch party and
this is where you heard your pre gamers
to the party and you say be fun be fun
and talk to people and like make this a
cool party right so this is where they
show up they're highly engaged they're
committed and they're inviting other
people and this is where the three you
know the four metrics you need to be
thinking about for your launch always
and this is where your product starts to
shine right so the party if you're
hosting a party it's the party that's
shining if you're doing a product launch
is where the product shines but you've
sort of done all the pre-work now your
product is sort of set up for success so
it still needs to work it needs to be a
good product but you've definitely
mitigated a lot of the risk of like
launching and having everybody just sort
of having a lackluster launch I mean you
can see here 419 of our 500 like
pre-gaming beta test
attended our you know first day when we
opened they actually showed up logged in
seventy percent message 50 percent
invited friends and we didn't even have
a launch party so this was all pre
funding pre you know we spent thirty
five hundred dollars to get essentially
on this entire five-month pre-party and
then they are ambassadors which I called
him now our founding members they really
did the rest and they brought in people
and the product really grew from there
and these small numbers I just wanted to
like highlight them because you know
four hundred and nineteen people logging
in it's not a lot right so it's you
don't have to have a million downloads
or when you read the like techCrunch's
like you just realized that you you can
start small and grow you don't have to
your launch doesn't have to be a million
users so um and then so we actually do
this for every city launch you can see
our New York launch which we did five
months later we had a pre-party and then
we had a real party and then to be even
more meta this all was actually before
our real launch in New York so like the
whole parties are actually pre parties
so we really believe strongly in pre
partying and we ended up launching the
next week after that so we launched like
May 7th and we had the party April 28th
and I really like this method because I
think expectations are just lower you're
not doing a launch party you're doing a
pre parties and people are just getting
oriented with the brand and so I really
I really feel strongly that the pregame
is actually way more important than the
party itself so to recap when the party
is good everything's good people are
inviting people the first experience is
awesome and so the way to ensure that
the first experience is awesome for
people you don't know is make sure you
have a pre party for the users you do
know and get them really to be your
ambassadors and behind every party is an
epic pregame so that's sort of like the
key takeaway here so now I'm happy to
open it up for any Q&A
we got to have her two quick questions
hi my name is Fallon Austin I'm the
founder of trial answer calm and I love
this presentation I've never heard the
idea of pregame would apply to business
I think it's a terrific idea and I was
hoping with my specific business you
could give me some suggestions it's
going to be on online marketplace for
copywriters and the copywriters are
gonna give you little demonstrations of
their writing abilities before you
choose them what kind of free exclusive
kind of giveaway comes to mind I love
the ideas you had but I'm not sure that
the bars scenes although bars is always
very fun which translate to an online
marketplace like mine what do you think
so I'm really into building community
right so if the copywriters are kind of
your your bread and butter these are the
people you need for your company to
survive right so I think doing whatever
kind of they're looking for are they
looking to network with other
copywriters are they looking to network
with people that are gonna pay them I
really do I mean you say the bar seems
not good I know a couple copywriters
that do very well at the bar scene so I
do think that just bringing people in
person together and offering them maybe
it's a copywriter that you you bring in
that can talk about how they worked
their way up and inspire the more junior
copywriters but I I do think in-person
events because you just get so much more
loyalty from people who know the face
behind a brand and it's again it's not
scalable at all like you can't do that
like we can't even do this in LA already
but it's for launching when you're
launching from nothing it's so important
like I mean if you can talk to 500
people in person before you launch I
would HIGHLY encourage it so I would say
talk to them ask them what kind of
events they want to go to and then
create some of these events and they
don't need to be expensive like you any
bar will tell you oh yeah you're gonna
bring 40 people to my bar on a Monday
night when I usually make nothing like
sure why don't you have the back room so
it's it's a very like cheap and easy way
to get people and so yeah I would I
would kind of go go work with the
copywriters and sort of win them over
I love it thanks a lot if anyone is
interested in drinking with copywriters
sign up at trial answer calm and we'll
figure out where the event will be how
come
hi I'm Anna thanks for getting your
stories thank you sharing your story
question I have is you talk a lot about
building a list and then invited them to
the party one of the biggest concerns
about building a list is those leads
going cold before they convert what's
your number one strategy stopping that
so building a list that's why I try to
not build lists so we didn't even use a
website for we always had an app in the
App Store and for some reason I do I'm a
pretty big proponent of like not having
people go to a website to log it to get
their email address and then asking them
later to go to a App Store and download
it that's like asking someone for two
things so we didn't even start getting
collecting email addresses until we had
an app in the App Store that could work
and that way I only had to ask them once
to do it and I could do it when I'm in
person and be awkward about and be like
hey download this I want to get your
opinion on this one onboarding issue
we're having so you can almost like arm
twist people into downloading it and
then they're kind of that yours for life
so that's one piece I would say and then
as far as keeping them warm I mean you
see how many events we had right so we
were emailing every month being like we
have another cool thing like Redford or
come to our fleet week party and so
we're always sort of inviting them to
things and even if they didn't show up
they kind of had a positive association
with the brand because we weren't ever
asking him for something we were always
just inviting them to things and so I
think yeah I was worried too I was like
five months is a really long time to
like keep these people hanging but we
tried to really nurture them and always
be kind of giving them something every
three to four weeks all right Thank You
Amanda well thanks guys